aleppo residents search for survivors
instead they find bodies rebels say
government attacks across northern Syria
have killed more than 70 people 12
civilians have reportedly died in Aleppo
City alone this is a residential area
there are civilians women and children
here look at this destruction Assad is
losing battles on the ground that's why
he's doing this a british-based watchdog
accuses Bashar al-assad's government of
dropping barrels filled with explosives
on two towns under Islamic state control
the government has repeatedly denied it
uses the controversial weapon the air
strikes over Aleppo follow on the heels
of recent is gains around the country
earlier this month is took Palmyra now
it says it's destroyed a notorious
government prison there the tad more
jail once held thousands of political
prisoners the building is a symbol of
the brutality of Assad's regime is
militants have posted pictures of the
prison's destruction online but the
building isn't near the city's ancient
ruins which observers fear could also be
destroyed by the militants